WE WILL TALK TO HIM.
SEE YOU IN A FEW MINUTES,
14 MINUTES AWAY ON BILL HEMMER
REPORTS.
>> Dana: WELCOME BACK, LET’S
BRING IN BEN SHAPIRO, HOST OF
THE BEN SHAPIRO SHOW PODCAST.
I WANT TO TALK TO ABOUT THIS
BILL THAT THE PRESIDENT SIGNED
TODAY BUT JUST BEFORE THE SHOW
STARTED, THE CONGRESSIONAL
BUDGET OFFICE PUT OUT THIS
NUMBER, THEY ARE ESTIMATING A
12% DROP IN THIS CORNER,
ANNUALIZED AND EXCEEDING GDP
THOSE ARE THINGS WE THINK ABOUT
A LOT AND GET YOUR TAKE ON THE
PRESIDENT SIGNING THIS BILL AND
WHAT HAPPENS ON THE OTHER END OF
IT.
>> THE UNDERLYING MARKET
FUNDAMENTALS CHANGE.
WE CAN TELL PEOPLE THAT THEY
STOP BEING IN LOCKDOWN AND IS
GOING TO CHANGE FAIRLY RADICALLY
RADICALLY.
JUST NOT GOING TO BE EATING IN A
RESTAURANT RIGHT NEXT TO
SOMEBODY FOR A LONG TIME, NOT
GOING TO A SPORTING EVENT FOR A
LONG TIME, HIGHLY CROWDED FOR A
VERY LONG TIME BUT IT ACTUALLY
MEANS IT’S MORE IMPORTANT, NOT
LESS THAN IMPORTANT TO GET
PEOPLE BACK SO WE CAN SEE OF THE
MARKETPLACE ALL OF THIS OUT, WE
CAN SEE WHICH AREAS OF THE
ECONOMY ARE GOING TO GROW AND
PEOPLE CAN MOVE FROM JOBS THAT
NO LONGER EXIST TO JOBS THAT
WILL EXIST BECAUSE THE ECONOMY
WILL MOVE IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION.
IT’S A SUDDEN SHOCK AND IT’S
GOING TO TAKE A WHILE FOR THE
ECONOMY TO RECOVER.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THE TENSION BETWEEN THE
DESIRE TO REOPEN AND THEN ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF IT, SOME PEOPLE
INCLUDING THE MEDIA LOOKING OUT
AT THEM AND SAYING IT’S TOO
SOON, DON’T BE FOOLISH, AND
YOU’RE HAVING THIS REAL ALMOST A
CULTURAL DIVIDE.
>> I THINK THAT A LARGE PART OF
WHAT’S HAPPENING HERE IS
AMERICANS DO UNDERSTAND OR WHAT
THEY SHOULD UNDERSTAND, THERE IS
NO SITUATION WHERE EVERYONE IS
ABSOLUTELY SAFE.
WHERE PEOPLE GO BACK TO WORK AND
NOW THEY CAN GO WITHOUT MASKS
AND SOCIAL DISTANCING AND THE
RISK LEVEL IS WHAT IT WAS BEFORE
ANY OF THIS HAPPENED AND I THINK
THAT THAT NEEDS TO BE CONSTANTLY
REINFORCED.
I ALSO THINK IT’S IMPORTANT FOR
POLITICIANS NOT TO PLAY THE
RIDICULOUS GAME WHERE THEY
SUGGEST THAT IF ONLY WE SAVE A
SINGLE LIFE THAN ANY POLICIES
JUSTIFIED, POLICYMAKING IS
ALWAYS ABOUT WEIGHING COMPETING
VALUES AND WEIGHING EXACTLY THE
COST TO NOT ONLY HUMAN LIBERTY
BUT HUMAN PROSPERITY.
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN YOU HAVE
30 MILLION PEOPLE SUDDENLY OUT
OF WORK.
THESE ARE SERIOUS CONCERNS AND
ONLY UNSERIOUS PEOPLE SUGGEST
THAT ANY POLICY THAT’S GOING TO
BE TAKEN WILL NOT HAVE COSTS AND
RISKS.
THAT’S WHY ANDREW CUOMO WAS
GOING TO END UP OPENING UP
NEW YORK UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
RISK STILL EXIST FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
THE SAME THING WILL HAPPEN IN
ILLINOIS AND IN CALIFORNIA.
THE QUESTION IS HOW THESE
GOVERNORS ASSESS THAT RISK AND
EXACTLY WHAT THE CURRENT
LOCKDOWN MEASURES ARE DESIGNED
TO DO.
I THINK VERY OFTEN, THEY DO A
POOR JOB EXPLAINING WHEN THEY
SAY FLATTEN THE CURVE, THAT WAS
DESIGNED TO PREVENT THE CAPACITY
OF THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM FROM
BEING EXCEEDED.
WAS NOT DESIGNED TO PREVENT
EVERYBODY FROM GETTING IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
THAT’S JUST NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
THE TESTING REGIMEN THAT PEOPLE
ARE TALKING ABOUT PREVENT SPIKES
BUT AGAIN PREVENT THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM FROM BEING
OVERWHELMED.
THEY ARE NOT DESIGNED TO PREVENT
HUGE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE FROM
GETTING IT OVER A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME.
UNDERSTANDING THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE
TO BE MORE SANE IN THEIR RISK
ASSESSMENT AND TO BE MORE
RATIONAL ABOUT WHAT EXACTLY
SOCIETY IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE
COMING OUT OF THIS BECAUSE IT’S
A ROSY OPTIMISTIC PICTURE IS A
DANGER AND I THINK SIMILARLY, A
PESSIMISTIC VERSION OF WHAT THIS
LOOKS LIKE IS ALSO GOING TO BE A
DANGER.
>> Dana: THERE WAS ALSO THIS
PROBLEM THAT IF YOU REOPEN AND
PEOPLE ARE EXPECTED TO GO BACK
TO WORK, THE CHILD CARE CENTERS
ON THE SCHOOLS ARE STILL CLOSED,
HOW ARE THEY SUPPOSED TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS?
>> THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
I THINK IN THE END, WE LIVE IN A
REPUBLIC, INDIVIDUAL CITIZENS
WILL HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS THAT
DON’T THREATEN OTHER PEOPLE BUT
ALLOW THEM TO LIVE THEIR LIVES
IN A WAY THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH AND THAT RISK ASSESSMENT IS
GOING TO VARY BASED ON PERSON.
TO PRETEND OTHERWISE IS
POLITICAL LYING.
>> Dana: BEN SHAPIRO,